la gráfica de una función f x se muestra
a continuación destaca un intervalo
donde f x sea menor que cero así que
bien aquí esta gráfica de la función
tenemos el eje x en la horizontal y el
eje y que toma los valores de fx en el
eje vertical así que la función f x sea
menor que cero simplemente quiere decir
que tengo que agarrar una parte de la
gráfica que esté por debajo del eje x
por ejemplo podría hacer cualquier cosa
por acá aquí en la gráfica está debajo
del eje x o cualquier cosa por acá donde
también la gráfica está por debajo del
eje x así que vamos a elegir a este
intervalo y vamos a ver comprobar
respuesta bien estamos en lo correcto
hagamos otro ejemplo
la gráfica de una función efe de x
demuestra continuación destaca un
intervalo donde nuevamente f x sea menor
que 0 misma idea la gráfica tiene que
estar por debajo del eje x así que
podemos elegir cualquier intervalo desde
aquí hacia la izquierda o podría ser por
ejemplo aquí también la función es menor
que cero y aquí también la función es
menor que cero podríamos elegir
cualquiera de ellos vamos a elegir aquí
en medio
muy bien uno último destaca ahora un
intervalo donde fx sea mayor que 0 ahora
queremos que la gráfica esté por encima
del eje x no por debajo así que veamos
la gráfica está por encima entre el 2 y
perdón entre el menos 2 y el 3 así que
puede ser cualquier intervalo aquí
digamos este muy bien espero que ustedes
puedan hacer los demás ejercicios solos